je de la moitié des jeunes américains
ont maintenant leur premier téléphone
intelligent avant d'entrer à l'école
secondaire 53% c'est la part des enfants
américains qui ont un cellulaire à l'âge
de 11 ans un enfant sur cinq l'obtient
même avant 8 ans une vaste étude de
common sense média conclu que ces
appareils apparaissent de plus en plus
tôt dans la vie quotidienne des jeunes
et les accaparent de plus en plus leurs
fins les portiques vous en êtes lui
passent en moyenne plus de sept heures
par jour sur leur téléphone en combinant
souvent des activités devant plusieurs
écrans comme les textos et les jeux
vidéo visionnement de vidéos en ligne
représentent près de la moitié du temps
facile sur leur téléphone
seulement 3% de ce temps est consacré à
des activités créatives virtuel comme
l'écriture ou le dessin
[Musique]